hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show so uh this is actually i
guess like the first one that's going up
in the new year of 2022 so happy new
year to everybody out there i know that
i said like when i was doing the
december reviews that oh maybe i'll do
winter themed
horror movies like for the rest of the
winter because i actually really do like
those
but then i don't know like during one of
our live streams some of someone asked
uh when i was gonna start doing more uh
jlo movies and i thought yeah it has
actually been a while since i've done a
giallo movie and i actually really do
like doing those and there's a bunch of
them on my list that i need to watch so
i said why not uh we'll start out 2022
doing uh another giallo film and one
that i hadn't seen before one that's
actually been on my list for a really
long time there's some that i've seen
before that i actually want to get
around to as well but because this one
i guess was like easier because it's on
2b for free and uh it's on amazon prime
and i figured well i've been wanting to
watch this one for a while because this
one comes up in a lot of people's lists
of like best giallo movies and i haven't
seen it uh this is the black belly of
the tarantula from 1971 which is
probably one of my one of my favorite
giallo titles of all time it's so great
i mean they're all so good i love like
giallo movie titles but this is like a
really good one and it does actually
sort of have something to do with the
plot which a lot of them
sometimes they don't you know what i
mean but this one actually does kind of
tangentially have something to do with
the plot
so this one came out in 1971
and i feel like this was if it wasn't
the first one that came out it was one
of the first batch that came out sort of
in response to
you know dario argento's seminal uh
giallo filmed bird with a crystal
plumage this is one of the earliest ones
that came out like after that i believe
it came out the same year now that i'm
thinking about her maybe like the next
year or the bird with a crystal plumage
i thought that was 71 too but it was
like pretty soon afterward
now this was actually directed by paolo
cavara
now as far as i'm aware this is the only
giallo movie that he directed but he did
do a bunch of other kinds of movies he
did spaghetti westerns he did crime
stuff probably most famous though for
mondo connie which uh you know one of
the better known you know shock
documentary type of things kind of like
i guess it's you know for americans i
guess something more like faces of death
or something like that uh so he kind of
did a lot of those kind of like
exploitation
true life like
uh documentary type things so that's
probably what he's best known for but he
did all kinds of other different films
as well
but this is pretty much i think is the
only the giallo that he directed now
interestingly i'm gonna say this is
actually a pretty solid jello film i can
totally see
why a lot of people
put this on their list of like really
really top ones um obviously it's not as
great as some of you know dario
argento's ones or whatever mario bava
but
this is a really really solid uh giallo
has a lot of the you know tropes that
jello movies have but has like a couple
different little things in there to kind
of like mix it up a little bit
so what the story behind this one is you
know obviously it's a murder mystery
like all the uh jello movies are
this one is kind of set more or less
around sort of like a fancy day spa type
of thing
uh which is good because it gives the
movie
the opportunity to show like lots and
lots of naked ladies
interestingly though
there is a lot of nudity in this but
it's not it you know it so it does have
a little bit of that sleaze that we like
so much like from jala movies but it's
not as sleazy
as some of the later ones i feel like
because i know there was some that were
like strip nude for your killer and ones
like that that were a little more on the
sleazy end this has a little bit of
sleaze but it's mostly pretty classy but
there is a lot of nudity in it so it's
like a lot of you know hot ladies uh you
know taking their tops off so you know
if you're into that
uh then you'll totally be into this as
well
not super super gory the kills are
interesting but and they're if you think
about them they're really upsetting but
it doesn't really show a lot you know
what i'm saying so it's not like this
over-the-top gore like you know like i
said like some somebody dario argento
stuff is but the killings like i like
the concept behind the killing so it's
based around this sort of day spa so the
first uh woman that gets killed is this
woman named maria
and she is they find out later on uh
she's apparently a nymphomaniac so like
pretty much the opening scene of this
movie like over the credits and
everything
she's at this day spa
and she's totally naked and she's
getting a massage from this uh blind
masseuse
and then later on she's in her house and
she's kind of like awakened by a noise
or of like the dog is barking and when
she takes the dog out the killer comes
in and like uh ends up killing her now
the killer in this one looks pretty much
like your standard giallo killer uh you
know the black fedora black overcoat
whatever the only thing that's different
is that instead of black gloves he
actually has like surgical gloves uh
which you know was kind of an
interesting touch
now what this killer does that's kind of
makes him different from some of the
other giallo killers
is that his thing
is that he has like these big uh
acupuncture needles and there's actually
a great scene of him kind of like which
is kind of funny when you think about it
there's like a scene of him with these
acupuncture needles very meticulously
put it like putting the needle like over
a flame i'm guessing to
you know like
well it's like we can't have germs all
over this if we're gonna use it to kill
somebody and it's like i don't know
that's just really funny to me but yeah
so it's like putting over over flames or
whatever so uh so they have so he has
these needles and what he does is that
he'll chase his victim around and then
he kind of like holds her down and then
puts the needle in the back of her neck
and it paralyzes her so it's kind of
like
um one of those things where it for some
weird reason i thought of uh that movie
wolf creek or the guy was like he'd had
like this spot at the back of your neck
and it paralyzes you but you're still
aware of everything that's happening uh
you know he calls it head on a stick so
i guess it's kind of like
that sort of thing where it like
paralyzes the victim so they're still
conscious of what's going on but they
can't move or fight back or do anything
so they just have to lay there with
their eyes open and watch as this killer
you know essentially cuts open their
stomach
so the reason that it's called black
belly of the tarantula which they kind
of
you know get into later on
is that apparently this is a real thing
i guess apparently there's this species
of wasp
and their thing is that they will get
into fights with a tarantula
and the wasp will sting the tarantula
and
incapacitate it so it can't move and
then it lays its eggs inside the
tarantula's stomach while the tarantula
is still alive so that when the eggs
hatch into larva the larva can
essentially eat the tarantula from
inside out because nature is nasty
but yeah so that's like a real thing and
they do actually kind of show that
happening
later on like during the investigation
so this first woman that gets killed um
she was a nymphomaniac like i said she
had been having fights with her husband
they were separated and so he's kind of
acting sort of sketchy like because he
said oh i haven't seen her in like 10
weeks or something like that but he'd
actually been at her house the day
before so the cops are kind of like
thinking that maybe he had some [ __ ] to
do with it also they find this picture
in the apartment of her and she's naked
and it's it's torn in half but you can
see like this there's this other man's
hand and it's not her husband's hand so
she's been like [ __ ] around on them
even though like i said they're
separated so there's kind of like
from the beginning there's kind of a
whiff of
uh maybe there's some like blackmail
kind of stuff going on as well
so
our main character like our main guy
that's investigating all this
is a dude named inspector tolini now
he's played by giancarlo giannini
and um he was in gosh i want to say i
think he was in
the 2006 casino royale now that i'm
thinking about it i think he might have
been in the hannibal in hannibal as well
like the movie hannibal from 2001 and he
was in a couple other giallo movies as
well i think he was in one called libido
which i haven't seen
and uh but yeah so if you want if you
watch giallo movies like to any great
degree you're gonna see like the same
people like popping up it seems like
there was just one stable of actors and
they would kind of turn up in i mean
because they made so many but they would
like turn up at all these ones
so inspector tulini comes in like i said
the the husband maria's husband is
pretty much the first guy because he
lied about where he was like because
they found out that he was actually at
her house the day before
his fingerprints were the only ones
found in the house other than hers and
the cleaning ladies so they're kind of
like following him around and [ __ ] like
that
now uh talini also has his own thing
going on where
he has a wife
and there's a very bizarre scene this is
kind of one of the things i love about
jala movies is there's some stuff in
here it's just so [ __ ] random
so i guess they're trying to like set up
character development or whatever but
there's this whole i wouldn't call it a
subplot because it's only like a couple
of scenes
but there's this whole little
tiny subplot about
talini's wife
um selling all their furniture like all
the old furniture in their apartment and
then having it picked up and then buying
new furniture there's like two scenes of
that and it's just like i thought that
was gonna like amount to something i
should have known better
but it
doesn't it's just in there just like
randomly like i said i guess it's
they're just trying to set up i don't
know what they're trying to say but
there's there's like a quite a quite an
extensive like several minute scene
of you know him coming home from work
after this horrible investigation and
her being like oh hey here's a check i
sold all the furniture they're gonna
come get it and then they come get it
and they're like hey um we still need it
though you weren't supposed to come till
tomorrow and there's like a whole thing
and then later she buys some new stuff
and he's like what'd you buy with the
money and he's like oh that that and
that so it's just i don't know it's like
really really funny but so inspector
tolini he's actually like a great
character in this he um yeah giancarlo
giannini plays him
as the movie goes on he gets like more
and more sympathetic because he's a cop
um i don't really think they say like
how long he's been a cop but all of
these murders that start stacking up are
really seeming to like get to him and
he's basically keeps telling his wife
he's like look i i'm gonna quit i really
don't think that i'm cut out for this
anymore you know i just can't really
take it you know the violence and it's
horrible and
all this other kind of [ __ ] um but then
he kind of feels compelled at the same
time he kind of feels compelled to like
go on with the investigation like as he
gets like drawn further and further into
it
so as i said they're investigating the
first murder
uh and then another woman ends up dead
this woman is she just works at um at
like a shop like a dress shop or
something like that and the killer comes
in and does the same thing to her like
puts the acupuncture needle in her neck
and then cuts her belly open um and they
find and they find out they're like well
obviously this is the same killer
but
inside the dress shop where she worked
was like a [ __ ] ton of cocaine so like
i'm guessing
this shop was like a front for some kind
of like cocaine or like drug trafficking
ring or something so they said okay well
now we need to like investigate that
angle too because it's possible that
you know because like i said they kind
of like um are going with the idea that
maybe these are all people that are
being blackmailed for whatever reason so
maybe because this woman
was involved in a cocaine ring somebody
found out about it and they're
blackmailing her blah blah so they're
like this is the same killer so
obviously they all have to be connected
somehow this is actually a really good
sequence like where she gets killed
because you can tell that
the director was maybe homaging blood
and black lace with a little bit because
there's kind of like some scenes where
she's running through the back of the
dress shop trying to get away from the
killer and like all these mannequins are
like kind of falling on her and stuff
it's like a really good uh chase
sequence but she ends up getting killed
so like i said they're looking for some
kind of connection between these two
victims uh at which point i think at
this point like talini actually ends up
going to
an entomologist to ask about
uh or i guess the entomologist calls him
because he's like well i i thought it
was weird and tells them about the wasp
and the tarantula thing he's like
because that it reminded me very much of
how the killer is killing his victim so
i thought i should let you know now
while he's in the entomologist office
interestingly he notices that like all
of these tarantulas that this guy has
they're in these little plastic boxes
with what appears to be sand at the
bottom but then like when the when the
cop like looks at he's like yeah that's
not sand that's cocaine so there is like
some more stuff about cocaine
trafficking but
in a way like the cocaine stuff and the
blackmail stuff
it does play into
sort of uh the larger mystery or the
murder you know the series of murders
but not really so a lot of it is just
kind of like red herring type of stuff
which
you know maybe might frustrate some
people but like i said it's very common
in giallo movies to have all of these
sort of subplots or all of these sort of
motivations for the killer that turn out
not to be the case which i guess is kind
of like a real investigation uh so you
know i can't be too mad at it but yeah
so don't get too invested in like the
whole cocaine because the entomologist
guy he gets arrested and that's it's
never brought up again the black male
does play into it
but
in the end the person that ends up being
the killer i'm not sure if i want to
spoil it because like i said it's hard i
know it's old this movie came out in
1971 and this one i did guess who the
killer was
but
you can't really guess who the killer is
from the plot clues you know what i'm
saying because like i said you're kind
of all wrapped up in this oh it's like a
cocaine ring or it's blackmailing
because they spend a lot of time on the
blackmailing angle like all of these
pictures like somebody's going around
it's this woman and she's the woman that
runs the spa that we saw at the
beginning and she's going around taking
pictures of people who are [ __ ]
around their husbands or whatever or
wives or whatever and blackmailing them
so all of the victims had that in common
but it doesn't really play into
the killer's motivation
so
you can't really guess if you're just
going by the plot beats
you're not gonna figure out who the
killer is
but i just figured out who the killer
was
because
i just figured it was the least likely
person because there's a couple scenes
in there that i was just kind of like oh
that's that's got to be the killer then
now for a while at first i thought that
the killer was maybe a woman because
sometimes they'll throw that loop in
there like just to throw you off but
then like when i saw a couple of the
shots and everything i'm like yeah
that's not a woman that's not walking
like a woman um you know it doesn't move
like he doesn't move like a woman so it
is a man but but i did kind of think
that like for the first few minutes but
then after that i started thinking i bet
it's i bet it's this guy and that's
exactly who it was and like i said he
doesn't
it sort of has to do with the blackmail
[ __ ] but not really it's honestly just
like in a lot of glo movies it honestly
has something to do with more with like
a psychosexual motivation like a whole
like impotence type deal it has to do
with that so really the person that's
killing the people it's
killing the women it was more like an
impotence like you know lashing out
because they were impotent um you know
and they hated women and you know the
fact that they were being blackmailed
there was a relation but it wasn't like
exactly the same so like i said there's
kind of like
so more women that end up dead talini uh
is kind of like investigating all of
these different things there's actually
like a really great when they first find
out who one of the blackmailers is
there's a really good extended like foot
chase which kind of reminded me of uh
one i think it was in the cat of nine
tails like the dario argento movie and
it kind of reminded me of that of some
of him like chasing one of the
blackmailer people like around like the
like on the roof of this tall building
and uh it's really great it's like
really shot really nice and it's like
really really tense and everything and
then one of the people like ends up like
falling off the
falling off the building and [ __ ] like
that but it's really really good it's
really well done uh so there's a lot of
really good scenes like that as i said
this is not a real lurid one it's not i
mean the cinematography is really nice
but it's not kind of one of those like
real like super colorful or like super
it it does have like a lot of those roll
early 70s like mod interiors with all
those really weird
weird shaped couches and lamps and round
chairs that are like orange and [ __ ]
like that it does have a lot of that
kind of stuff going on but it doesn't
have but it's not like super colorful or
super
stylized it's pretty naturalistic
looking but
it's stylish though not stylized but
just kind of stylish in a way that a lot
of the movies from this uh era were uh
the score was actually done by ennio
moricone who did a lot of a lot of these
score not not super memorable and it was
actually it's a little bit strange the
score for this one actually it sort of
sounds like it uses a lot of like
women's sighing uh in it in a very weird
kind of way it almost sounds like
softcore porn music a little bit which i
guess maybe a lot of jala movies their
music sounds like that but
which it doesn't make much sense at the
beginning but then like later when you
learn what the killer's motivation is in
a very like uh scene at the end which is
very much like the end of psycho where
we're like explaining what the killer's
motivation was
which i don't mind that is you know what
i mean but i'm just saying that was
maybe an homage to that um so when you
find out what the motivation was like
like the the kind of sexy sounding music
makes more sense you know what i'm
saying but while you're watching the
movie and you think this is all like a
black male plot or drug trafficking or
something like that it doesn't make as
much sense even though there are a lot
of like naked ladies in this but yeah
you're seeing like a lot of the same uh
people
turning up in this i mean pretty much
everybody that's in this you will
recognize from probably some other
giallo movies uh there's actually a guy
in this who works at the spa
who is kind of like he says he's a
waiter but i guess he's basically like a
gopher person and he's playing this is
another thing that happens in a lot of
giallo movies where they have like the
token gay that's like way that's like
way campy and like over the top um so
he's playing that kind of character he
was also in the house with the laughing
windows which actually is a is an
excellent excellent gel if you haven't
seen that one i'll probably get around
to that one one of these days too
because i really really like that movie
um but there's some other women in this
too that you will recognize uh barbara
bach is in this uh she was in short
night of glass dolls uh rosella falk is
in this she was in seven blood-stained
orchids which is also pretty good
um you also have claudine azure auger
not sure how you pronounce that uh she
was in twitch of the death nerve aka bay
of blood
uh barbara boucher she was also in
torture a duckling i'm pretty sure
barbara boucher as soon as it came on
like i know i'll get into like the whole
james bond thing in a minute because
there's a bunch of bond girls in this
barbara boucher i'm pretty sure i'm not
entirely sure because i forgot to check
i recognized her she's like the first
victim she's the first woman that gets
killed and as soon as i saw her face
i said oh my god
that's baby woman from ancient
agent from harm um which is like this
really cheesy like spy knockoff movie i
saw it on mystery science that's why i
call her baby woman because i saw it on
mystery science theater and that's what
they called her because she has like a
very like babyish like this kind of like
angelic beautiful face and so they
called her baby woman the whole time and
as soon as i saw i was like oh my god
it's baby woman but uh i'm pretty sure
it is her yeah but uh yeah but she was
also in don't torture duckling the lucio
folgi uh jala movie and uh you also have
uh silviano tranquilly who i think plays
the first victim's husband i'm if i'm
not mistaken uh he was in the
bloodstained butterfly which is also
pretty decent uh but yeah there's
there's just all kinds of people from
other uh gela movies and as i said
there's also a lot there's three
three bond girls in this barbara boucher
who i just mentioned was in uh she
played money penny i think in the
original casino royale from 1967. uh
barbara bach who has also been see some
other jello movies but she was also in
the spy who loved me
and claudine ager or auger or aj i'm not
really sure
she was actually in thunderball and the
guy that plays tellini in this giancarlo
giannini he was actually in the 2006
casino royale so there's a lot of bond
connection in this which is very strange
because
this isn't it's italian but you know
what i mean uh so yeah but pretty much
everybody in this has been in other
giallo movies or a bunch of them were in
bond movies as well so you'll recognize
a lot of people
so as i said this is actually i can see
why this turns up in a lot of people's
like top 10 lists this is a real solid
it's not my favorite it's not as crazy
or lurid or anything like that the kills
are
cool for the concept but they're not
real graphic they're bloody but they're
not gory um but i really do like the
idea of you know paralyzing the victim
with the acupuncture needle and then
like cutting their stomach open and i'm
saying they cut their stomach open they
don't
they don't like show
it you know what i mean it's not like
suspiria where it's like you show the
heart like the exposed heart with like a
knife going in it uh it's not like that
it's basically just kind of like a knife
going in the stomach and then there's
just blood it's not like
this really really gory kind of thing
but honestly the first sequence where
barbara boucher's character gets killed
is really really well done it's really
well shot like the way the killer is
like chasing her through the house and
it's like these big windows and uh you
know she's wearing this kind of flowy
chiffony like yellow thing like robe
situation and then like you know he
busts open her her uh pajamas and he's
like you know she's just laying there
like that with her boobies and you know
what i mean and then he's like cutting
her stomach up but yeah so you know it's
it's a really good solid uh giallo film
like i said i guessed who the killer was
but that didn't really diminish my
enjoyment of it it does go off on a lot
of
weird tangents like i said the whole
thing about
the furniture being sold there's a very
strange scene where the killer or the
blackmailer i guess it's the blackmailer
videotapes or records from like across
the street records talini having sex
with his wife
and then
leaves it for the police to find so then
like all the cops are watching it and
they're all like snickering and i was
just kind of like
i was i was like he's having sex with
his wife it's not like he was having sex
with a goat or you know or he was
cheating on her or something like that
it's like so i just thought that was
very very weird and he's just like
sitting there the whole time going oh my
god this is so embarrassing and uh you
know it's just like there's a weird [ __ ]
like that it's not funny it doesn't
really have any funny kind of stuff in
it the only really kind of sop to
comedy i guess would be
you know the token gay character but
he's only in it for like a second or two
and it's not
real over the top i think the funniest
thing about it is that he's kind of like
a dick like to all the women that go to
this spa like for no reason like this
woman's in the pool and she's like hey
give me a cigarette and he's like okay
and then he just like drops it in the
pool and he's just like oops you know
what i mean so it's like i kind of liked
him though but he was only in it for
like
uh for like a scene or two but yeah so
that's pretty much the only funny stuff
it's not like real funny and uh you know
but it's a good mystery
um you know i really like the whole the
whole tarantula and wasp angle like i
said it's not the best one i've ever
seen i you know i prefer like a dario
argento's ones because they're more like
operatic i guess and like i said i'll
get around to doing house with the
laughing windows as well which
uh the guy that played the token gay and
that was in in this was in that movie as
well so i'll get around to that too but
it is definitely definitely one worth
watching and if you're into giallo
movies and you haven't seen it it's
probably one of the
foundational ones like after you see
kind of all the big heavy hitter ones uh
this is definitely like the next tear
down of like ones you need to see
because this is a pretty i guess this is
like a pretty typical example but it's
still pretty entertaining i mean i had a
really good time with it
uh watching it and all the spiders and
stuff like that so uh you know and some
of the shots are pretty great so yeah as
i said it's on amazon prime i believe as
of this recording and you can also watch
it on to be for free uh 2b actually has
a bunch of gela movies some not they
have like a few of the kind of like real
well-regarded ones and then they have
kind of a lot of the
sort of like lower tier like schlocky
ones too uh i think strip nude for your
killer is on there actually maybe i'll
get around to you in that and this they
have like knife of ice and stuff like
that so uh so yeah so if if you want to
go on off on a jello kick you could
certainly do worse than going to tubey i
think this actually was on
shutter but i don't think it's on
shutter anymore at least not in the u.s
i think was on there for a little while
but now it's not on there anymore but
you can totally watch it for free on
toby
and i would recommend it if you like jlo
movies and if you haven't seen it if you
have seen it uh what did you think about
it let's talk about it in the comments
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye